Welcome to another Zoom call.
Several questions came in so let's jump right into them.
Just a reminder to to look on the members only site.
For all announcements and the new announcement is just.
You know, you all have been announcing if you've been on the Zoom calls that.
You know, the powers that be the boards are constantly trying to attack doctors like us.
If the dozens and dozens of doctors admitted a soda that down.
I've got letters for the boards who were one of them even though we're not admitted a soda anymore, they have no jurisdiction over us.
But they're really restricted.
You know, how emailing questions and responded by email and personal one on one call.
So we'll try to move everything to the Zoom.
Platform.
We just have to do that in order to stay safe.
So please, if you're in the habit of emailing questions, look at that point right there because we really need to discontinue answering any questions.
That I just have to take the questions and should email and put them in the Zoom call.
And it would be easier for me if you just submit those questions on the members site if you will.
Then also remember that all you guys are get free access to all our courses use the same user data password.
As you do for.
For everything else.
And these are all our courses.
Correct.
Got an auto mail course that I'm working on that will be out in.
Okay.
First question.
Just received a call from my oncologist C. T for this afternoon confirms cancer is now in the liver.
You first recommended it in a biopsy, which I declined.
I then said there are.
He then said there are blood tests to find.
I guess to further check invasive.
To further address what I would like to know because those types.
What I would like to know does Dr. Perez change the right to further address the liver involvement.
Would there be any suggestions?
So,
I do want to address the first part here.
If there is thought that there's metastasis to another organ, like the liver, it's not
uncommon that an oncologist is going to want to do a biopsy of that area, just to
confirm that it's a metastasis.
But how would you know it's a metastasis?
Because the biopsy would come back as the same type of cancer.
So let's say I have colon cancer, but it testicizes to the liver.
It isn't liver cancer now, it's still colon cancer cells.
So in that case, if it is a metastasis, we don't change the rife program because you're
not running liver cancer programs, you're still running colon cancer programs.
So there is a need to change that.
So should I do a biopsy?
Well, if there is not that the cancer is another part of the cancer, we have multiple patients
that have two different cancers at the same time.
But it's not common.
Plus, you have to look at the initial type of cancer you have, does it commonly metastasize
to the liver?
Well, a lot of cancers metastasize to the liver that's a colon type for metastasis.
What's the chance of that being a separate cancer that needs a separate type of treatment?
Pretty slim.
What's the chance of the biopsy causing more harm than good?
You could argue that that's might be high.
So it's nice that your oncologists will look at other ways to decide if it's the same at
no carcinoma type than to be able to do a biopsy and push you towards that pathway.
Also, oncologists don't, they may strongly suggest it because it is the standards of care
practice to do a biopsy, another site that might be seen on a CT scan or a PET scan.
But I think a lot of oncologists, if it was them, they wouldn't necessarily do that.
So they don't typically push that hard.
So, added this question, does Dr. Cutters change the right?
If it is a metastasis to the liver and metastasis to another organ, no, you don't change the
right.
It's the same cells that are metastasized to the bone or the lung or the liver.
So there's no need to change the right program.
If it's a separate standalone primary cancer, then yes, you need to run frequencies for that
other cancer.
So, how would you know that?
The only way to know this to a biopsy, which you got to kind of play the odds of it, too.
So the perfect example would be like, if I have colon cancer, then I have this vast of my
thyroid.
This colon cancer, ever metastasized to the thyroid, but I don't think there's ever been any
published data that the colon cancer would metastasize the thyroid.
99.99% chance, if it is cancer in the thyroid, then it is a completely different thyroid
cancer instead of colon cancer.
So yes, then you would change the right programing to include appropriate frequencies for that
other primary cancer.
In the past call, you said not to sleep with the grouting pan or the ion whip pan.
Is it okay to sleep with a half sheet grouting pan, whether the grouting sheets that you sell
at your site, does it work okay with nightly use of the right machine?
Yes, it does.
I suggest that you use it on the lower half of your bandwidth on your full bed.
I suggest using it on the waist down where your waist would be more than likely when you're
lying or sleeping in your bed, put it underneath your fitted sheet from the waist down so
that the idea is that the possibility exists that if you roll over and your ball was laid
on the sheet and you're two feet away from the ball, you're losing a lot of frequencies
right to the ground if it's laid on the groundy sheet and you're getting less going through
your body.
So if you're really good at holding the ball on your chest and stuggling with it on your
belly and stuggling with it and you sleep on your back all night, then you could actually
have it on the full sheet.
I don't see any problem with that at all.
If you roll over to your side at all and the ball beds up on your side and get it going
to the right height and you have the sheet of the full part of the bed, then you could effectively
be losing some of the frequencies right to the ground because that's what's going to be attractive to.
I'm going to answer this question multiple times on multiple Zoom calls.
I'm pretty sure we haven't split up on the right portion of the member site to release
and look at that in a light answering questions again that's no problem but do look at the right
questions, do look at the right section of the member site as well so that you can kind
of not have to wait to answer, get to the answer to your question.
What are the suggested cutters, protocols for peripheral verapricate?
There are both.
So it really depends on what the cause of the peripheral verapricate is, so let's finish the question.
I visited a clinic that works with their apathy patients and their protocols use the Rebuilder.
This is a newer model than the one you sell.
The Rebuilder 2407 is a Rebuilder 300 plus an EMS machine piece to a two and it's far more expensive.
You don't need the EMS piece to the machine so we don't sell this one specifically for that purpose.
You don't need that higher, there's no need for that higher cost piece if you have neuropathy so we only sell the Rebuilder 300, that's fine we sell them.
Secondly, light therapy for angiogenesis.
So I think they're giving you a little bit still where light therapy, they may be doing laser therapy.
They're calling it light therapy so it might be laser therapy.
I would ask them what class laser they have.
So lasers come in a class one, two, three, four, four.
There's also lasers that are called three B lasers.
I would find out what class laser that they're using.
Laser for peripheral verapathy can help too, so that's enough.
That isn't good therapy, but if they're using a class one laser, or even a class two laser, and you know, you'd have to use a lot of time with a laser like that to really see any change with their apathy.
You really have to go to a three B or four laser, so I would ask them what class laser they have.
Anabolic management, what would you suggest?
Well, the biggest thing for verapathy is vitamin B6.
But again, you're also dealing with what type of verapathy.
So person has peripheral verapathy due to peptide.
Beaty sits a totally different metabolic management that peripheral verapathy due to chemo therapy.
So with chemo therapy, you want to help detoxify through your feed too.
So using your iron pro wave would be another thing.
So I would agree with using rebuilder.
Rebuilder stimulates at the frequency, electrical frequency of the nerve itself to help regrow their pathways.
I would agree allheartedly with laser therapy, especially if it's a class three B or four.
Metabolic management for peripheral verapathy in general, no matter what cause would be B6.
And then secondly, if the class is a if the cause is a from chemo therapy induced peripheral verapathy,
then you have to look at detoxification and we already have you are things for your detoxification pathway.
So there's no things to add for that.
But I would definitely add the iron pro wave.
How long would you guess the right programs for neuropathy take for someone with neuropathy for three months and as approximately 30% neuropathy to the feet.
So it depends on a couple factors.
So if there was no more assault or no more causation.
So in this case, if you have chemotherapy induced neuropathy and you stopped doing chemotherapy and you're not doing any more chemotherapy,
still you have damage to the nerves that have to heal and nerves heal very slowly.
So you're going to look at multiple months before you're going to see changes, plus it depends on how bad the neuropathy is.
So neuropathy is damaged to the peripheral nerves and you damage the type of nerves that you damaged first,
are called the large diameter, a ferent nerves, those are the nerves that carry centering back to the brain.
You have small diameter and large diameter a ference and those are the large diameter efforts that are damaged first with chemotherapy and with diabetic neuropathy.
So you'll have the same symptoms with either one of these types of neuropathy and it's going to be tingling in your feet and then you'll get numbness in your feet and you won't feel your feet finally.
So so it depends on how far you progress to that path.
So if you have numbness in your feet or you don't feel your feet, the next thing you're going to feel as those nerves come back to life is pain.
And it's tingling. So you're going to go through that what you went through getting to the point of numbness, you're going to go through that again.
So your symptoms when you start working on your neuropathy, your symptoms of neuropathy can actually worsen before they get better because you're waking up to nerves and helping them regal.
Well, again, and you're and these are a ferret pathways a ferret pathways means they're carrying sensory information back back to the brain.
E ferret pathways are carried information from the brain to the tissue, in case this case, they're remote or pathways.
But the a ferret pathways that are damaged have to regrow again and when they wake up, you're going to feel more pain.
So you may get feel like you're getting worse before you get better than it takes time. How long is it going to take you can better if you're still doing chemotherapy.
Well, it's just you're just battling, you know, it's it's it's an endless because you're causing more damage every time you do the chemotherapy.
So, I would say, you know, that you're doing high on pro waves daily.
And that's why I'm big into you having a rebuilder at home so that you can do it, you know, twice a day.
It's hard to have a laser at home because they're pretty pricey, but you can certainly have a rebuilder 300 at home, I don't know about 800 bucks.
And you already have the idea of, so you could do most of this work at home, if you're going into a clinic and doing it three times a week, you're going to much more limited success.
So that would be my suggestion.
The last couple of weeks have been a roller coaster. I'm sorry to hear that.
I think I experienced my first healing crisis.
I retired from my job of 20 plus years and had my quarterly CT scans, all things are pointing positive. Thank you.
But I'm dealing with some aftermath.
Accomplished a few coffee enemas. Is it common to have a metallic or bitter taste afterwards or even a dull feeling of indigestion.
I do really enjoy the mind clarity.
So why would a person get some clarity of mind if you're doing a coffee enemy because you're stimulating a parasympathetics and a parasympathetics.
That's what I said. Do a lot of good things that stimulate your immune system, they stimulate your detoxification pathways, but I haven't talked a lot about is it stimulates the rest of relaxation.
You're a logical pathway in your brain.
So it can be very comforting and relaxing to your brain.
So coffee enemas could be very beneficial for that reason.
I think it's a good way to have a metallic or bitter taste afterwards.
Well, it's possible with the coffee enemas to have that. I'm not sure if it's connected directly to the coffee enemas.
I don't know. There could be a neurological. I don't know. I can think about that.
There is a lot of past anxiety that I would feel daily with my job, anxious to start by day, night sweats, work related dreams, any tips to cope through this temporal emotional problem.
But it's like I still have nightmares about testing that I didn't study for the test that I haven't told the class all semester and I'm in trouble.
And that was 35 years ago. So it is, it is when you have this performance type anxiety.
And there's some things to work with the coffee enemas will help with that adaptogens.
So the first thing you think of with any of that anxiety is adaptogens. The second thing we think of with anxiety is is making sure you are watching your glutamate consumption.
So glutamates originates. What's the most common glutamate? What is sodium glutamate? Where do you get that? Just what any prepared meal is about any restaurant we go to. You're going to be consumed. You're going to be consumed by the sodium glutamates.
Well, glutamates why would they put glutamates in food? Because they stimulate your brain. Glutamates are an excitatory. They're a transmitter.
And it makes you think, wow, that was really tasty. And I want to do that again. That's why they put glutamates in food because it makes you buy the food again. And so.
So glutamates will increase anxiety and increase so CD and increase ramped up behavior and looping on a thought and you know thinking about a subject and can't get your mind off of you.
You can't let it go and that is a glutamate issue as well. Also could be an elevated serotonin level.
Serotonin can do similar things when it's elevated. That's why you have to be careful with taking excess metal groups. So this because you have a MTHFR gene defect does not mean you need a whole bunch of mental groups that can produce excess serotonin.
Especially if you have any M.A.O. defects that's a gene that is in your mind after pathway that you want to make sure you look at your genes. So you don't let excess metal groups, but none of you are any excess metal groups for us. That's for sure.
Because they can also turn out turn off to the suppressor genes and we don't have you taking any of those.
But also I would say given the night sweatses in there that you commented on adaptions would be my first choice because it can be tied to hormones to so adaptogenic herbs.
You have multiple different adaptions on our website. You probably have some in your home too. If you search adaptions on our website and you look at some of the ingredients, you probably have a couple of bottles with nutrients that are adaptions.
My blood work looks like I am about anemic. My energy is low. Lots of naps. I've done some blood rebuilding with the right. How many sessions could I do back to back? There's no limit to how many sessions you could do with the right back to back. Any other strategies to consider. I am also trying to get more protein back in the line.
The B vitamins will help build your blood. And then you may have to consider hired. So it depends on how it even you are. However, there's multiple types of anemia. If you have anemia, but a disease, you also have your whole blood cells. If you have anemia, folate, that's an issue that's different.
If you have anemia, B12, that's very common. So taking the drugs normally might be the one or two. If you're going to take iron, whoever use our iron, protocol, or you take our to be with it.
You talked about a LKP. That's an acronym for alkaline phosphatase. Else in the blood work last week. I got my blood work back in late August. First my alkaline phosphatase was 90.
Went up to 115 October 24. Still fighting lots of body aches. Long COVID. We're walking the media. I don't know.
Using clear in them just does not cut the pain. Ordered so much for us to just use it last night. It helps some of my body just aches, especially by legs.
Okay, so if the alkaline phosphatase is raised because of liver congestion, that's one thing. So we don't know that exactly.
But to support that, you could think of using a hot pack over your liver, doing coffee enemas, doing castoral packs over your liver.
If the alkaline phosphatase is raised because there's retastasis to the bone, and there's the only lytic erosion of the bone, that's a totally different story.
It might be helped with using 3gcg, which can help to decrease the inflammatory process that's going on at the bone.
Dressing that is important too. That the pain and the body aches kind of concerns me.
I don't remember who asked this question, but if you don't know that you have any metastasis or you hadn't confirmed that that isn't the problem, then.
Then, then, you know, if it's confirmed that you have no voting metastasis in the alkaline phosphatase is raised, just raising just because of the liver, or liver congestion, or that is something else going out of the liver and stick to the to the suggestions that I gave.
If you know that you have voting metastasis, and that's the reason for the alkaline phosphatase rising, then the clear inflame will help with that too, but that wouldn't be my first choice for the pain.
I would also make sure in your blood work to look and see if you have elevated blood calcium levels, so that's another hint that there's some lytic function going on.
Your blood calcium level is even at the high end of normal. It wasn't it was within the middle and middle of the range.
In the previous test, that would be another kid that that it's caused from an elevation of the only lytic growth.
So you want to make sure that you're addressing that in some way too.
That can give you pain in your legs also also pain in your legs can be caused from an ebius to make sure you look at your cbc as well.
Because I heard deficiency can be causing that too.
Well, this is like a part of the question. What else could I do to provide red blood cell coat on both that's told me that's supposed to be an ebia that can be causing for your legs.
You may need to be taking iron. If you do take iron, make sure you add art emisited as well. So if you have art emisited at home, I would take capsule of art emisited with the iron.
So just take a good type of key laden iron, not what the data prescription iron that would be very salty, which is hard on your gut.
So like our clear iron or there's some other there's other good iron products.
Most reputable nutritional companies have a good source of fire, but you do want to take it with an art emisited.
There's the ways that you can do to get your red blood cell count up as eating beats and eating red meat and things like that that is going to have the b vitamins in it as well.
And like I said before, b vitamins.
My breast tumor has been very sore also not sure if it is coming into coming to the surface more or now last that I run some about to rob that's a CD.
For the store and fragrance and so on and it called the tone so CBD creams can be very beneficial as topicals.
So that's good news. I email my blood results in and you hope you understand them. Yes, we can still do one of ones for that and you can make an appointment with me.
For that.
All right, the chat is not working for some reason of this zoom call. So you'll have to unmute yourself if you have a question and voice it in.
Dr. Connors. Yes, sir. Can you hear me? Yeah, this is Steve and just curious. I've been trying the life one protocol along with everything else and it's just a lot of healthy supplements, of course, as you probably know, but one of the things that says in order to allow it to help you more because I've had chemo.
So I want you to take a D around with taste or some sort of estrogen blocker of sorts and just curious what your thoughts are about that.
So estrogen blockers, you're talking about like dead and things like that natural estrogen blockers. Yes, that's correct.
So a lot of people think that those are only for women and that is a huge myth.
We are all exposed to exogenous estrogen since estrogen is from our environment better exposed to just as many as women.
Just because women make more estrogen in their body and then do men still make estrogen.
But it isn't the estrogen that you make in your body that is the problem. It's the exogenous estrogen. The estrogen that you get from the environment.
So then eat dim almost as much as women need dim dim is just one.
One thing that can help block bad estrogens. Look on our blog under aroma tastes to start typing aroma tastes.
And you'll see multiple blog posts on aroma tastes and inhibitors.
So aroma tastes is an enzyme that's made in all your cells.
And it's more potent in your fat cells, your fat cells are the cells that store hormones.
So if I have excess hormones today, they can either get dumped into my colon and be exited into the toilet or they'll be stored in my fat cells.
And then they will aromatize through the process of an enzyme called aromatase into hormones.
They'll be they can aromatize into different metabolites of testosterone and estrogen.
And that can cause problems. So there are so if anybody here has done the Dutch test, the Dutch test is a dried urine or bold test. It's the most accurate or bold test.
If anybody here has done that, you'll see that you have a lot of different metabolites of your hormones, you don't just have testosterone and estrogen and progesterone.
So you have all these under metabolites. This can matamilite is a converts to be converts to see converts to D and D is really the unit the most utilized form of estrogen right.
So if you have a testosterone and hydroxyesteroan and two hydroxyesteroan and 4 hydroxyesteroan and 16 hydroxyesteroan and it's the 4 hydroxyesteroan pathway that can be very damaging and be a major player in cancers.
How do you get rid of those? Well, you get rid of those naturally through pathways, but the problem is is that we have so much extra estrogen that we're exposed to that we get an abundance of 4 hydroxyesteroan and that can be very damaging to ourselves.
Even if you do not have an estrogen receptor positive cancer or hurt to positive cancer, it can still be a player and a cancer.
So I'm very careful not to give people way too many supplements, but you got to consider at some point that maybe taking something to help with that with pulling out bad estrogen will be a good idea.
Now, we have a new product called a robot clear and it's meant to be a play on a robot taste.
We have to be so careful how we name supplements. That's a private label supplement. And I believe it has calcium be generated and it's limited as something else that I can't think of it on top of head.
But that is going to be one of my new favorite supplements to use for polito bad estrogen. So look into that.
So I know a lot of people are like, I'm tired of taking supplements. I don't want to take any more supplements. I'm not saying that everybody needs to take that.
But that can be a good player at some people's point.
Hello.
I wanted to ask another question about my heavy metals test that came back so high in the gadolinium after my MRI in August.
I was kind of freaked out by that, but then as I researched a little bit more.
It seemed like maybe that wasn't as horrifying as I thought, because it would seem to mean that the gadolinium hasn't completely settled into my brain and my tissues yet. It's still
circulating and I'm flushing it out through my urine. So that's
okay. Is that okay thinking or is that totally off missing the mark?
So clarify was the was the heavy metal test you did a urine test?
Yes.
Was it a provocation test?
What does that mean?
You take a bunch of key later beforehand?
No.
Let's do a 24 hour urine.
Yes.
Okay.
So in one sense, yeah, well, I've get it out. It's in my urine.
So there really isn't any great test for heavy metals.
So there's the hair analysis test. Well, how accurate is that?
I don't know. To be honest, I don't put a ton of faith in that.
There's the urinary 24 hour urine test. Usually it's supposed to be a provocation test.
Meeting that you take for a couple days, you take a very strong kind of overdose on key later.
And then you do a 24 hour urine.
I don't like that test at all because of you're basically pulling a bunch of stuff out of the tissues.
And what I call phase zero detoxification process, and you're dumping into the blood.
And basically overwhelming your liver and these are going to circulate around and dump somewhere else in the body.
What doesn't get out in the in the colon of the urine?
I jump in here one second because I, I just remembered I did have to take a pill in warning before I started.
It was 500 milligrams. I think of something or other. And I don't remember anymore what it was.
It was probably either DMSA or EDTA.
Yes. Yeah. It was. Those, that sounds familiar.
Yeah. So I don't, that's why I don't like those tests because you could actually.
You could make the person sick.
So I don't test for heavy metals with lab tests.
To me, that's, that's my only two choices, which it is.
I don't, I don't do that. But yes, you are, that tells you that you are, when you take a key later, you're pulling it out of the tissue and you're dumping it.
That does still tell you that you have a lot again, Lydia, maybe you.
Now that may indicate that the pathway in which you get rid of gadolinium, you do have some hindrances there.
It would be interesting to do a study of a hundred people that did an MRI and one month later you do that same test and see how many of them have elevated gadolinium.
You will need to bet that it would be a small amount.
Because not everybody has issues with gadolinium.
They're able to readily get rid of it.
It's maybe on the, in a tea pathways or the pun one pathways probably.
So there are some people that have such issues and get rid of gadolinium that they end up getting really sick and there's, there's websites.
People that have, you know, gadolinium toxicity disorders.
So most people don't have problems with it. This would suggest that you have some.
Just, you know, that's why we try to use a homeopath because it's a mild key later.
What else could you do? I would look at the mild key layers.
If you want to add anything else to your protocol again, I would also mainly support your liver detox pathways.
So if you haven't read the seven phases of detox book that might be helpful to put the whole picture together to make sure that you're, you're not pulling stuff out of the tissues and then it's getting blocked in a damn somewhere downstream and then just circulate around your body and could actually make yourself more ill.
You're having really good bowel movements and you feel like, you know, you don't have any gobladder issues.
Then looking at phase one and phase two pathways in the liver, that's your, that's your site of chrome people 50 and your pun one pathways.
I don't know your genes on top of my head, but if you have any pun one issues, which most cancer patients do, maybe ramping up the pun one products.
It would be in order.
How the credit is a good food to support the pod pathway as well.
Those are the kind of things I would look at.
I did notice that I, I saw I still have some chlorella and spirulina powders laying around as a good to throw those in my smoothie for now.
Yeah.
Ending those up and then maybe get after I'm done with those get another key later.
Maybe I would use mild key later is like that though.
And if I'm taking pun one already I'm taking four tablets a day. What does that mean if I'm going to ramp that up?
Well, maybe for a time being go up to six a day.
And remember the nice thing about the capsule versus taking it in a smoothie is that you can take it more throughout the day because you have a happy.
It's just something that's having a half life in your body. So if you can kind of keep that support of.
Because your liver is working 24 seven, you know.
And so if you can, you know, take split that through the day every three hours. That would be best if you're good at doing that.
Okay.
All right. And I by the way, I did come across the research that where they have tested people who had a contrast.
They got into time. And they found Catalonia and in their system years later elevated.
Yeah, it can be because of a kind of lady and there's an element of the periodic table and it's kind of half life of about 20 billion years or something.
Seems like it. Okay, thank you.
Dr. Connor.
Yes.
would it be okay to switch that to the
aerobic layer? Yes, you could do that.
Yeah. Okay. Okay. Awesome. And then lastly,
is there like a list of
supplement or natural supplements?
Um, but if it's something that I may be
comparing, you've already tested before.
Um, that's a good question. Why don't I have a list of things?
Okay. Um, if you want, you know,
typically if people are thinking of taking
something more, they just start taking it,
if they feel like to take it, and then they'll
make mention of it on their next
cheeks won't test. So I get that a lot.
Hey, I started taking XYZ. Can you just check
and make sure this is good for me or a
patient's time? Okay. You're wet.
Dr. Connors, um, I had the that ALKP was 115.
My calcium was 9.5. Okay.
So that's pretty middle. Um, I think
the orbital goes up to 11.5. I can't remember
the normal range for calcium, but I think it's
kind of a look at that again. But um, the calcium
you tried to send me, did you reset your blood
work? Because it didn't. I did.
I did. I did. And then also, um, my red blood count
to get that up. I've been trying to eat beats.
The red meat, I'm, I'm supposed to limit
since I'm on a low histamine. Yeah. Um,
and I, I did get the B12, the pro hydroxyl
colabin, then from you. So, um, one of those
that'll help to the pro hydroxyl cubology. Yeah.
Right. Okay. And that will help too.
If you're only limiting the red meat because of histamines,
I would add some of that to my diet. Okay. So the
fresher, the better if you're trying to stay
away from histamines. Okay. So lunch meat would not be
the first choice. Right. Right. No, we have our own
beef. So, oh, well, that's good. Yeah. Then you could use that.
So that calcium is pretty, I mean, that it says on the sheet,
8.6 to 10. Yeah. But 9.5 is on the higher.
Yeah. So then you're at the high end. And that, you know,
do you, um, we can talk when we go over your blood.
Okay. Okay. I'll call and make an appointment.
Okay. All right. Thank you.
You bet. Yes.
So let's say let's say the person
sends in a cheek swap, but let's say they were doing some research.
And they, um, and they thought, oh, I heard this talk on, um,
I got to mute you while I answer this. Okay. Um, I heard this talk on, um,
Pactisol C. And oh, my gosh, I just, I think I should start taking this.
Um, but I'm taking so much stuff.
And I'm sending it at a cheek swap next week anyhow.
So I'm just going to ask Dr. Cutters, can you check me on Pactisol C2?
I really feel that I should take this too.
Um, now again, by all means, I am not perfect.
What I would a person's protocol together. I'm not gone.
So just want to put it out there to everybody.
So you all understand that I do not want you to put your faith in me.
Nor do I want you to put your faith in your protocol.
Nor do I want you to put your faith in the right machine.
Nor do I even want you to put your faith in new healing.
I want you to put your faith in Jesus Christ and Him alone.
But I want you through the process of life which all of them
throws us curve walls like cancer diagnoses that leads you to a deeper relationship with Him.
And when you're questions, if you don't have answers to even something
in the grand scheme of things, simple like should I take Pactisol C?
Um, it should lead you back to, I'm going to be great about that.
And I'm going to seek God's peace in that.
You know, you're going to see the heavens open and God come down and say yes,
take Pactisol C. That's so.
But you God doesn't need us through His Holy Spirit in different things.
And yes, He uses other people and yes, He uses, you know, doctors and yes, He uses,
you know, your spouse and, um, but, but you have to have that ultimate relationship with Him.
So you have, well, I want you to feel free to ask me about things.
But I'm just giving you my opinion and it might be an educated opinion.
Um, but it's still just coming from a fallen man that maybe regenerate but is still sinful.
So don't take what I say as gospel truth either.
You've got to weigh it all out, um, in, uh, in your relationship with God too.
So you need to be trusting Him and seeking Him for that answer.
So even if I tell you in your protocol that I want you to take
XYZ supplement and you just have something deep in your heart.
I don't feel, I just, I just don't think I should take this.
Then by all means, you're not insulting me by, well, I want you to be obedient to God more
than it is. So, you know, do, do follow the leading of the Lord.
Part that struggles in our life are to drive us to a deeper relationship with Him
so that we, we can hear that still small voice inside of us that leads us in different directions.
Maybe sometimes in very different directions than what others maybe trying to push us in.
So you need to learn that's what maturity is is learning to, to hear God speak to you in ways
that are just gentle and, and not just that's how he talks to us. He doesn't beat us up.
He doesn't shame us. He doesn't kill us. He doesn't make you feel bad about yourself. He encourages you.
He loves you. You're a child and he treats you like a chosen vessel. That's what you are.
So, let this cancer be something that drives you closer to Him.
If your cancer is getting better, then he gets the glory.
If your cancer is getting worse, then yes, seek him for it. Ask him for healing. Ask him for
a different direction. But the truth is, and I share in my personal story, and I do recommend that
you do go back and watch those videos. There's time, and there's going to be a time I get in my life
that I'm going to be near death. And I had to struggle through those things too. Like you,
baby now, or you are going to in the future, we're all going to die. And when we get near that time,
we need to be driven closer to Him and accepting what His will for us in our life. And
ultimately, our whole purpose in this walk that we have on earth is to be molded and shaped.
More to the image of the sun on a daily basis. We're going to sin constantly. We repent to
death. Forgive this God. Forgive this freely, because we are His children. But He wants us to be
closer to Him today than we were yesterday. And I feel at that all the time. And you will too. And
that's okay. That's part of your walk. That's part of growing. That's part of it. Sure. And that's okay.
So please, I don't, I want you to take what I give you on the Zoom calls, take what I'm giving you
on your protocol. And take it to the Lord too. And it's okay to change things and do things.
It's not just okay. That's really your responsibility to do that. Take whatever doctors are giving
you and go, I'm going to pray about that and think about it. I trust your wisdom. But I trust
God's leading more than anything. And that's what I'm going to put my faith in. It was human.
Not anything else. So that means that if you have questions about your protocol and things,
and you want me to test something, do another cheek swab or recheck things. If you disagree with it,
you follow the leading of the Lord and what you're supposed to do. So often I have patients that
are working through their spiritual maturity. That's what sanctification is. You're constantly working
towards trying to be more mature with the help of the Holy Spirit. You can't do it yourself.
But it is growing in dependence upon Him. So that you're seeking it after Him in a deeper way every
every day. And that's why troubles happen in our life. So that we can grow mature and become
closer to Him. And ultimately, we focus more on eternity than we are this present day.
So that's my encouragement for you all today. And I guess it's a good place to close. So
remember I'll be back with you Monday. I do ask that you continue to pray for everybody else on this
Zoom call. Everybody else that is members of our practice, all of our staff as well. I do ask that
you pray for Anne. She's going through a lot of struggle with her 19-year-old son, AJ.
He was just physically crashed. So I've shared this a little bit if you've been on a Zoom call before.
They thought it was his chronic life that flared. His fatigue was he literally couldn't get on a bed.
But then they did a blood work and his platelets were just plummeted.
And there was something drastically wrong. He was diagnosed with acute myeloid leukemia.
It's a very aggressive leukemia. He's in the hospital. He had a chemo therapy finished a few
weeks ago. He's getting a bone marrow biopsy tomorrow. And she said, I could share this story because
the more people that are praying, the better. So I do ask her prayers for her. And those will be
cherished. So thank you for that. All right. I do love you all. And I pray for you all the time.
I usually wake up at about three o'clock in the morning and doesn't let me sleep until I'm
praying for all you guys. So know that they don't just say that. So with that, I will see you Monday.
Get your questions in on the member site. And have a good next few days. Bye bye.